what's up Greg i'm Danny Gonzalez and
this is the wired autocomplete interview
if you told me all of these questions
are from my mom
I would probably not want to answer a
lot of them honestly
okay
what does Danny Gonzalez Greg mean Greg
is what I call my fans on YouTube
um it's sort of like how Grateful Dead
has deadheads or I think Nicki Minaj has
Barbies is that Nicki Minaj okay back in
like 2017 when like Logan Paul and Jake
Paul were getting popular they had these
cool fan base names that were like puns
on their own name Logan's was low gang
and Jake Paul's was the Jake paulers
which is a lot less clever I wanted to
do something like that with my own name
but I couldn't come up with anything and
I thought it would be really funny if I
just started every video by saying hi to
some random guy named Greg what was
Danny Gonzalez job before YouTube I've
had a few different jobs before I was a
YouTuber when I was in college I nanied
like middle school kids occasionally
I'll still get a text from one of them
every now and again just saying that
they watch one of my YouTube videos or
asking if they can be in one of my
YouTube videos what is Danica Gonzalez
twitch yeah I do have a twitch Channel I
don't really stream very much anymore
but my twitch I think is just Danny
Gonzalez or maybe it's Danny goonzales I
don't really stream that much anymore so
probably not that much going on there
what degree does Danny Gonzalez have
okay I went to college I went to uh
Georgia Tech and my degree is in
computational media I often tell people
that it's computer science because it
sounds cooler honestly and nobody knows
what computational media is but
basically I had to take like half
computer science courses and half like
liberal arts degrees it's a degree that
a lot of people get when they're going
into like game design or like web design
stuff like that I did none of that I
make YouTube videos in my house what is
Danny Gonzalez personality type I have
taken personality quizzes before I don't
remember exactly what my personality
type is I think I've taken the one that
gives you like the letters like int J I
think is mine maybe
okay it's
ESTJ is the eve extrovert
I'm reliable to people who deserve it
you know uh self-assured not I don't
think so and steadfast I don't even
think I know what that means but I'm not
stead slow I sure as hell know that what
hair product is Danny Gonzalez use none
since I shaved my head honestly I just
step out of the shower and just let that
Drive am I allowed to swear is it
before I shaved my head I used a product
that you can get at Target called cremo
I think it's just like c-r-e-m-o cremo
creamo I'm gonna call it cremo so that
is all the questions on this one
okay next
does Danny Gonzalez have a tattoo I have
one it is a snail and it is right here
it's on my left thigh my wife Laura has
a snail on her right thigh they were
supposed to kiss
um but we accidentally both got them
facing the same direction so there's
just kind of like one snail following
another snail does Danny Gonzalez have a
podcast no I don't I've thought about
starting one before but I I'm not good
enough at having conversations or
talking for long periods of time so I'm
probably not going to do that if I were
to have a podcast I like True Crime I
feel like those are really interesting
stories but some of them are really
scary so maybe something that's like
really interesting stories that aren't
scary does Danny Gonzalez work at
Corridor no but I did I worked at
Corridor Digital for like maybe like
three or four months in 2018 and it was
like right as my YouTube channel was
starting to like blow up on its own and
so I like I started this job at Corridor
and Corridor was like one of my favorite
YouTube channels like all through high
school and college so I started working
there and it was like what my dream job
basically aside from obviously having my
own YouTube channel so I feel really bad
because my channel started to blow up
right as I got this job and then I quit
because my own channel started doing
well but they still make some of my
favorite YouTube videos that I watch
watch so they're awesome does Danny
Gonzalez have a dog I do yes I have two
dogs one of them's name is Sunday she's
a mix of a lot of different breeds she's
like a boxer Chihuahua Beagle mix cattle
dog is in there too and then I have a
dog zero who is a mini Australian
Shepherd zero looks like a little
stuffed animal Sunday kind of looks like
a dog that was taxidermied sometimes
because her eyes are like little black
beads they don't look real but they're
both very cute and I love them both does
Danny Gonzalez use auto-tune yeah I do I
use a lot of it so I make music I make
like comedy music I'm not a singer but
sometimes I want to make a song where I
sing so I use auto-tune and I'm not
ashamed about it technology makes our
lives better in a variety of ways and
this is one of them
foreign
a dad I sometimes call my dogs my
children I do worry that people who are
actually parents kind of are like whoa
dude you don't know what it's like to be
a real dad and I so I feel weird about
saying that but in the privacy of my own
home I do call them my children and I do
call myself their father but in a
literal sense no I'm not a dad I didn't
give birth to them or anything like that
is Danny Gonzalez a comedian I don't
know exactly what makes you a comedian
because I don't do like stand up I don't
act in movies I just make YouTube videos
but I do make comedic YouTube videos so
I guess it just depends on your
definition of comedian sometimes when
I'm talking to older family members or
people that are you know that just ask
what I do for a living if I don't want
to explain YouTube to them I'll just say
I'm a comedian and then they get it so
sometimes I call myself a comedian is
Danny Gonzalez real
deeply philosophical question for me to
answer I guess I mean I have no way of
knowing for sure
um if any of this is real so yeah I
guess there's your answer is Danny
Gonzalez sponsored by Lacroix no I'm not
I used to drink Lacroix in a lot of my
second Channel videos I was just coming
off of this thing where I was like
trying to stop drinking soda and so I
was like pushing Lacroix really heavily
in my videos at that start of every
video I would drink a Lacroix and I kind
of was hoping at some point that they
would be like yo that's really cool like
let's work together we'll sponsor your
videos that never happened is Danny
Gonzalez the fastest growing YouTube
channel okay this is actually kind of
up that this is on here because I
say in a lot of my videos that I am the
fastest growing YouTube channel but I
always preface it by saying do not look
that up and the fact that this is on
here means that a lot of people have
looked this up this is really
disappointing to see I'm not even gonna
dignify it with a response you already
know and so as far as I'm concerned this
does not deserve of a response so
who is Danny Gonzalez best friend that's
kind of a sweet question I don't think
I've ever seen anyone ask that before
online my best friend is my wife I know
that that's kind of some people you know
roll their eyes at saying that but she
is my best friend I spent all day every
day with her if I wasn't gonna pick my
wife I'd probably pick my dogs which
would also be kind of a cop-out so I
mean what do you want me to say who is
Danny Gonzalez dream last year on April
Fool's Day I did a fake face reveal as
the notorious Minecraft creator dream
because he had never shown his face at
that point he has now and it's not my
face the real dream actually like dm'd
me and said hey do you want to do like a
fake face reveal on my Twitch account I
got on his twitch I did like a whole
presentation about how I'm really dream
and like the whole thing was fake up
until dream face revealed a couple
months ago people actually thought that
I was dream they didn't know that it was
an April Fool's Day joke they saw it
after the fact when it wasn't April
Fool's Day anymore I am not dreaming
unfortunately I know I was as
disappointed as you when I found out but
I'm Not Who
it's Danny Gonzalez videos uh I have an
editor his name is Jake Mayer and he is
super talented he's a great guy he edits
my videos
um he also shoots my videos with me so
when I did a video recently where I went
to the Stanley Hotel Jake came with me
he is technically an employee and I did
feel bad like making him stay at a
haunted hotel I do feel like there's
some like ethical issues with that but
In fairness I did book him a non-haunted
room and he didn't see any ghosts as far
as I know who who does Danny Gonzalez
look like there's so many people the
newest one that I kept getting a lot was
the the new Buzz Lightyear from the
Pixar Buzz Lightyear movie I don't think
that shaving my head has helped I think
that I actually look a lot more like him
now that was not intentional I feel like
it's a lot of Pixar movies I swear that
like every time they looked for a new
character they like load the same 3D
model into their program and it's kind
of like a gangly guy with a large nose
and then they just like modify it a
little bit and then they're like this is
the new main character of the Pixar
movie so it's them okay it's not me
they're doing it I swear
where was Danny Gonzalez born okay I
feel like that's probably like a
security question on my bank account or
something so I'm gonna give a vague
answer
um I was born in the suburbs of Chicago
I've lived there for most of my life I
uh grew up in Wheaton Illinois so I was
born close to there
with my mom in the room where does Danny
Gonzalez stream I don't really stream
that much anymore but when I did I did
on Twitch there's a couple things I
didn't like about streaming one of them
was that I had to like read comments in
real time from people I feel like for
YouTubers or anyone that's online like
reading comments is like the worst thing
about like doing social media because a
lot of them are kind of mean and having
to read them in real time while people
are watching you is like the worst thing
ever I don't stream that much anymore
that is why but when I did it was on
Twitch when did Danny Gonzalez
get married another possible security
question but I will answer this one
because it's public information I got
married on July 1st 2017 the date
is a palindrome I think it's a word 7117
pretty cool a lot of people think it's
pretty cool
did Danny Gonzalez okay we're on to past
tense did Danny Gonzalez
dye his hair did I no I don't think so
I'm trying to think if I've ever dyed my
hair no no I didn't I shaved my hair I
cut my hair did I dye my hair no oh
maybe people ask that because I have
like a gray streak in my hair that's all
natural baby my dad has it too actually
he's got a little gray right here did
Danny Gonzalez
quit YouTube now I didn't quit YouTube I
want I do wonder why someone would ask
that though I feel like you could just
search my name on YouTube and like a
recent video would come up unless it's
like did he quit YouTube in the past
like day you could probably get a better
answer by just going to my YouTube
channel and I would probably post a
video being like I quit YouTube so if
you're ever curious about that again
just head on over to my YouTube channel
it's Danny Gonzalez and And subscribe
did Danny Gonzalez work on light year
this is a double layered question okay
because now we're getting into not only
do I have a lot of look-alikes Buzz
Lightyear but I also have several people
that have the same name as me there's a
guy that works on every Marvel movie and
a lot of like animated movies too named
Danny Gonzalez so I'm in the credits for
like every time a new Marvel movie comes
out I get a lot of tweets being like you
worked on the new Avengers movie dude
that's sick I did not it's some guy or
maybe I should just take credit for it
maybe I should say yeah it was me it was
me and then I'll have to change his name
yeah it was me I worked on light year uh
super great experience I actually I
actually was given the opportunity to
model the character to look exactly like
myself so that was did Danny Gonzalez
ghost Kevin Jonas I think so I think I
did there's been some recent controversy
about this because I made a song called
I ghosted Kevin Jonas it's about this
one time in 20 like 2015 I think or
2016. I was doing Vine at the time and
Kevin Jonas like dm'd me out of nowhere
and asked uh if I could do a favor for
him I dm'd him back I was like yeah of
course he either has a music label or
some kind of agency where he represents
music artists and one of them one of his
artists was working on a music video
they were trying to get a bunch of
viners to like lip sync to the same song
I guess so he asked me to do that and
then I just didn't respond I guess ever
so this did happen
okay last one this one just says Danny
Gonzalez okay they're just like making a
declaration into Google Danny Gonzalez
first video there's like a lot of
different answers to that question
because this could be like what is the
first uh video on my current YouTube
channel what is the first video I ever
posted to YouTube or what is the first
video that I ever made and there's a
different answer to each of them the
first video I ever posted on my current
Channel I think was just like a Vine
compilation because I was doing Vines at
the time the first video I ever posted
on YouTube was in Middle School I think
I think I started my first YouTube
channel in like 2006 with a group of my
friends we made a channel called
Highlight Zone Productions I think we
only posted like three videos on that
channel the first video I ever made I
couldn't tell you when I was uh when I
was probably like five my parents and my
siblings used to make like a Christmas
video every year which explaining this
to other people is really difficult
because I guess other people didn't do
this but we would do like a little
talent show that was like Christmas
themed and then and film it a lot of the
like talents would be like doing magic
tricks where we would have the camera
filming and then we would stop filming
and then I would like leave frame so it
would look like I Disappeared all of a
sudden Danny Gonzalez I'm gonna kill
Santa Claus lyrics so I'm gonna kill
Santa Claus is a music video that I made
based on the movie
um the Santa Claus with Tim Allen the
premise of that movie is that Tim
Allen's character accidentally kills
Santa and then for some reason uh from
that is entitled to become Santa there's
a clause that's like written in his
jacket I think that says like if you
find this then you're the new Santa now
and I've always thought that was kind of
messed up that if you kill Santa you
just get to become Santa but then I
thought about it and I was like actually
this is kind of cool and if I could get
my hands on this guy and actually do it
myself this could actually be really
awesome so I wrote this song called I'm
gonna kill Santa Claus most of my videos
are commentary videos but this one
that's just like a music video is my
most viewed video on YouTube I think
that it just passed 20 million views
Danny Gonzalez cool for the summer Vine
this was a Vine that had the song cool
for the summer by Demi Lovato it was it
was just joking about the lyrics I guess
the lyrics are uh don't tell your mother
kiss one another two pretty playful fun
lyrics and then the third one is die for
each other and I always thought that was
like a pretty big leap to make I mean
even the title cool for the summer
implies like a pretty light-heartedness
and then the lyrics are just die for
each other I always thought that that
was like a little bit of a little bit
strong Tick Tock more or less fills the
hole in my heart that vine left Danny
Gonzalez fan fiction this is probably
referring to one of my other most
popular videos it is uh me reading a fan
fiction of myself and Drew Gooden who's
another YouTuber and uh the fan fiction
is about both of us and both of us are
in the video reading it together and it
is a romantic fan fiction between us
it's like us and the Paul Brothers
there's like some sort of Love Triangle
going on between us somehow I think Drew
gets pregnant and then we get married at
the end I did read a fan fiction that
said I had a six-pack once and I was
very flattered by that Danny Gonzalez
end song for a long time my videos had a
song at the end called this video is
over now it's a video that I made myself
and honestly I kind of slapped so I put
it at the end of every video just as
like a fun little outro to my videos
I've since kind of stopped using it I
guess like YouTube really values like
what percentage of a video people watch
and I found that a lot of people just
like clicked off when I would play the
outro songs I don't know if it's had any
impact but I do kind of miss that song
it is on Spotify though so you can find
it so there you go
so I guess Drew Gooden did one of these
two I think that this video is gonna be
a little bit more interesting than his
video because these questions uh were
about me his was great and it was funny
and everything it's just like if his
questions could have been about me also
I feel like that actually would have
been sick that would have been a lot
funnier